kovat 19 is spreading rapidly in Dallas
County the data is clear our our case
numbers and our hospitalization numbers
which we've been tracking daily are
headed in the wrong direction that is
the mayor of Dallas talking about a
sharp increase of coronavirus cases
there that's just one example of the
bigger picture the number of Cova 19
cases surging to more than 38,000 in
America yesterday that is a record daily
high it surpasses the previous record
that was set two months ago so it's time
for a headliner Health and Human
Services Secretary Alix a czar mr.
secretary good morning welcome back
great tell you why thank you what's your
plan so we're working aggressively with
states and local leaders in this
situation but it's important for the
American people to know this is a
localized situation the counties that
are in hotspots are three percent of
American counties now that's not to
minimize the situation it's really
important that we get to the bottom of
why we're seeing the surgeon cases now
some of it clearly has to do with
increased testing we've tested over 30
million people three and a half million
just in the last week and the average
age of people testing positive is going
down dramatically
that means we're capturing younger
asymptomatic individuals which is a sign
of a very robust testing system that
President Trump has delivered but we
also need to get to the bottom of why
we're seeing such spreading so we've
deployed teams to the county level to
work with local leaders and community
leaders to figure out why we're seeing
this kind of spreading you know mr.
secretary thanks for being here this
morning people want to know first and
foremost if they're going to be safe
obviously but if they haven't returned
to work they certainly want to if
they're back at work they want to stay
there and they want to know if their
kids are gonna go back to school in the
fall do you see another shutdown
happening
I don't although you'll see local
community mitigation steps depending on
circumstances you know as I said the
hotspots are in three percent of
American counties about a hundred and
ten counties right now is are the ones
that we're focused on we can get back to
work back to school back to worship and
importantly back to health
care if we act responsibly as
individuals if we keep in mind what are
our individual vulnerabilities you know
most of the fatalities and severe cases
are in individuals who are 80 years or
older or 65 years of age and older with
three comorbidities such as diabetes
obesity renal failure lung or lung
disease these are the people that have
to be really protected ring-fenced
protected the rest of us obviously
should take sensible precautions none of
us want to get this disease but we have
to protect those individuals we can get
back to work we can practice social
distancing we can wear face masks if we
can't practice social distancing but mr.
secretary we certainly appreciate you
being here and you're talking to our
viewers you're trying to get out there
and be transparent with the Nate with
the nation but you haven't had a
coronavirus Task Force briefing in a
long time several weeks as you know from
the White House and at the beginning of
this crisis it was very important for
the president the vice president and
yourself to deal directly with the
American people I've heard you now in
this interview say it's a localized
problem to Sandra's question about
schools its local I get that that
happens on the local level but are you
kind of farming this out now to local
and state governments no not at all but
it's always a locally led state
supervised federally supported process
of responding and you've heard the
president the vice president myself
we've got dr. Falchi dr. Burks dr.
Redfield in fact the four doctors just
spent 7 hours testifying before Congress
this week so we're out there we're
keeping the information flowing to the
American people and we're supporting our
county and state leaders to deal with
this with transparent information and
giving them the support that they need
there's a piece in The New York Times
this morning
Trump's feeding America's coronavirus
nightmare secretary a czar I'll read it
to you we need a Churchill to lead our
nation against the deadly challenge
instead we have a president who helps an
enemy virus infiltrate our churches and
homes Churchill and Roosevelt work to
deceive the enemy the Trump is trying to
deceive us what do you say to that that
the president's leadership through all
this and now talk of a potential second
wave that we could be doing better how
do you respond secretary
listen these kind of partisan attacks
are just completely irresponsible as
we're in a pandemic we're all working
together the president the vice
president I were working with governors
and local leaders regardless of party to
work for the benefit of the American
people here and thanks to the
president's historic leadership we have
the tools to deal with this we have
surveillance we've got historic testing
systems we've got containment at the
local level we have hospital system
capacity and supplies for them we're
bringing therapeutics to market we're
developing vaccines at record speed
that's all thanks to the president's
tremendous leadership pulling not just a
whole-of-government approach but a whole
of the American economy approached
together on this he deserves credit for
that as well as the complete
transparency that he and his
administration have provided throughout
this crisis mr. secretary we haven't got
about 30 seconds but on the vaccine
question you seem to be showing some
optimism and dr. Fauci and others said
it's not a matter of if it's a matter of
when I guess is the way they were
putting it that they're very confident
that at least early 2021 we're gonna
have a vaccine how optimistic are you
sir I am optimistic given the
president's leadership here we are
devoting tremendous resources to ensure
that we reduce any any unnecessary delay
in developing a safe and effective
vaccine but also importantly we're
manufacturing hundreds of millions of
doses of vaccine at risk so that they'll
be ready if an FDA if a vaccine is
approved by the FDA so tens of millions
by this fall hundreds of millions by
early next year okay thank you these are
if I could just a final thought on just
the second wave listening to you talk
about the vaccine coming in January
obviously the flu season could come in
we all want to get our kids back to
school safely do you see that second
wave happening what does that look like
secretaries are so I don't think it's
useful to talk about first wave second
wave we just need to deal with the
epidemia epidemiology on the ground
right now we've got three percent of
counties that are presenting with rising
cases and we want to deal with them and
we use those six tools that I talked
about surveillance testing containment
health system resilience therapeutics we
now have three therapeutics we're
working with we've now got REM Devere we
have convalescent plasma
we have steroids and we're gonna keep
bringing menthe and bringing other
products like monoclonal antibodies to
market so we can keep reducing our
fatality rates you know any death is too
many but we now have fatalities in the
United States for over 16 days below a
thousand and our rate of fatality per
million puts us at the top tier of of
developed countries around the world in
terms of in terms of performance there
and protecting our vulnerable people
okay secretaries are thank you thank you
thank you